[Music]
let's go to marie in
pennsylvania hey marie what's up
hi dr john how are you we are rocking
and rolling how about you
i'm hanging in there oh goodness
gracious what's going on
um
i'm going to struggle through this so
please bear with me take your time take
your time
um
my 16 year old daughter um was taken and
admitted to the hospital on sunday due
to a suicide attempt oh marie i'm so
sorry
um
while she's been in the hospital
she was in direct extended contact with
someone that was a coveted positive
staff member
which has now caused her hospital stay
to be much longer than the normal stay
prior to going to a inpatient mental
health program is it because she's been
quarantined
um they haven't necessarily quarantined
her um like i'm able to stay with her
all day um they're they just need a
negative test after 10 days of the
exposure for the facilities to be
willing to take her
okay because because she hasn't
because she was in contact
correct okay um like at the hospital
they have like a one-on-one nurse with
her all the time
um
and that from sunday night to monday
morning a 12-hour shift that nurse
tested positive on monday morning and
she had spent 12 hours with my daughter
right prior
has your daughter had any symptoms or
anything is she sick no okay good deal
good deal yeah so can we do can we do
one thing real quick
sure
i want you to
hold your take as deep a breath as you
can and hold it
one
two
three and then let it out slow
it's really hard i know
but marie she's going to be in there for
10 days and we're going to let that one
go
okay
because you got a lot in your heart and
head right now and you're going to war
over something you can't change so we're
going to let that be she's going to be
there for 10 days there's going to be
surrounded by people who love her and
care for her she's going to get food
she's going to get sleep which are two
critical things right now okay
and so we're going to let that one go
yes cool absolutely
yeah okay great so she's there for 10
days great yeah what's next um
because of this extended stay it has
allowed me the opportunity to start
researching these facilities
oh no did you look online reviews
all of them marie don't look at the
online reviews
i wish somebody would have told me that
two days ago don't look at online
reviews of psychiatric care don't ever
do that
never never never oh no i'm so sorry
that you did that okay so has the
hospital recommended places for you
yes
and you checked them out and they were
miserable and evil and awful and all
that stuff
every review says don't dare send your
child there of course of course um
that's a whole show that is a whole show
um and and i understand i mean any any
information you get from people online
you're getting information
people leave reviews when they're angry
i understand that very few people um
i have had the the honor of sitting with
a number of parents who are pulling
their kids out of these situations
often
there is such deep and pro like what
you're experiencing right now such deep
and profound confusion
and grief and loss and mourning that it
is anybody i could possibly pin this on
please
and
psychiatric care facilities are really
hard and they range from
somebody who's 14 who says the words i'm
having dark thoughts and gets caught up
in a school system that dumps them into
a psychiatric care unit and somebody who
is acutely schizophrenic who has
tried to kill themselves multiple times
and they're all in the same room
so it can be terrifying and scary and
all those things and then you get a
parent or a mom who's got their own
challenge and then they go
they've got an opportunity to put it on
the internet right so i would tell you
to
not get on those reviews okay
and i know that's so hard because you're
just looking for the best info you got
it's so hard and these are expensive and
people get their kid out and they're so
grateful and they get this bill and you
get angry there right so all that to say
is there's not a lot of
um
there's not a lot of incentive for
people to put positive reviews okay
um let's back out for a second hey tell
me about your daughter
she not been doing well does this
surprise you so much i know
i know you do
um
she has struggled with
anxiety
being anxious and struggled with
depression for years
we have had her in counseling
she's been seeing a great counselor for
10 years
off and on i mean not every week not
we go through
peaks and valleys
where we will see her counselor weekly
for two or three months and then we'll
go six or eight months and
not really have a need and then
something will come up and we'll go back
to weekly for a little bit
what was your childhood like 10 years
with the same challenges like that lets
me know what she had come from a rough
environment does she have some
challenges that she experienced early on
what's home life
um dad and i divorced 10 about 10 years
ago
and that's kind of when all these things
peaked um
was there is there some challenges
before the divorce
um
i mean between me and her dad of course
that's what i'm saying yeah was it was
there some stuff that okay she was
living in that water is what i'm saying
she's breathing that air that's a better
way to say it correct okay okay um so
now we fast forward and again that's not
for blame that's just i'm trying to get
some context here
and then what happened
did something
did something
acute happened was there a trigger
moment here or did she just get
exhausted and say i'm tired
um i i think it's the past two years
just the chaos the
losing touch with friends um
i think that um
she
she's had um a serious boyfriend
and her and the boyfriend
have been
in age boyfriend girlfriend arguing
lately
and i mean that that has contributed to
some of her anxiety but i i really think
that it's just the past two years of
everyone's world being chaotic and
she's been at home doing cyber school
and
not having good contact with teachers
and
she did not
succeed in her freshman year of high
school she had to repeat her freshman
year because of the online
chaos that she just
i mean she just she didn't she didn't
succeed at that okay
and how did she try to take her life
okay
and she took 12 tylenol pms okay and did
she leave a note
no her dad found her okay
um
did he notify her did she send something
out on social media
um he found her in the bathroom
and
she was um from i was not at the house
of course she was at her dad's house and
um from what i understand he heard her
crying in the bathroom and he opened the
door and she was sitting on the floor
and her extremities were beginning to
turn blue yeah and he called 9-1-1 yeah
yeah okay
um
i'm glad he was there
me too i'm glad thank you
so now she's in a hospital
with around the clock here is that right
have they have they stabilized her she
said i wish um
i can't believe this happened i'm so
glad to see you like what's her state
right now
um she is
she wants me there with her all the time
she doesn't like when i leave
she has not talked to me about
the whats or the whys or the house i
haven't pushed i haven't really asked i
don't
i don't know if i should
um
she wants to come home
um but she she does say that she wants
help she wants to get better she wants
um to learn
how to handle
stress better like she knows she needs
the tools she she says that awesome and
she's willing to go to an inpatient
facility
um
but
she can tell that i'm anxious about it
yeah so i think that makes her anxious
about it gotcha so you nailed it just
there she will absorb you
and that's a lot of pressure on mom
and unfortunately that's what we sign up
for when we become parents
okay and she's going to absorb dad too
are you and dad on speaking terms are
you all co-parents here okay yes um
if possible at all and if y'all are both
married to other people now um it may be
good to bring them in too
but a
what i would call an emergency not an
emergency like there's lights flashing
but soon this week next week
i think it would be worth your time
to
go get with a local pastor a local
counselor somebody you could get in a
room with and say here's how we're all
going to walk forward
because what your daughter's going to
need is a united front of people who
love her and are going to hold her
accountable and give her boundaries kids
crave boundaries in the in the thing
that's most
um that usually happens here is everyone
pulls all the boundaries off because
they don't want to say or do the wrong
thing because they think this like i
don't want to be the one who
fill in the blank right and kids are
desperate for them
please give me guard rails right yeah
and but those guardrails can get
oppressive in looney tune also and so
it's just getting everybody in a room no
blame this is all about how are we gonna
love her moving forward and it might be
we're not gonna say i can't believe you
did that i we're gonna have to none of
that right and so getting with a
counselor can say here's five or ten
things we're all gonna agree on
and dad you're gonna write a letter
every week mom you're gonna write one
every day or fill in the blank right
um but getting in a room if y'all can do
that and act like grownups here and your
daughter's desperate for that
then everybody walks out on with a
united front okay
um the second is
yes she wants you there every time as
much as possible
and be there as much as you can but if
you got to go to work you got to go to
work and having somebody there who loves
her whether that's your i don't know if
you're remarried or if you've got other
siblings or an aunt or an uncle or some
a mentor some people can be there that's
great
if they can't they can't what would be
really cool in these moments is to have
a flood of people who love her write her
letters and just say we miss you and we
love you
and here's why that's so important she's
sitting in a hospital feeling like she's
alone and she's just got some nurse
sitting there on her phone
or reading a book or whatever
having something that she can hold
tangibly that when she starts thinking
i'm dumb i'm stupid i don't have this i
don't believe
she's got evidence on top of evidence on
top of evidence that that's not true
and there will be a little bit of
embarrassment and shame i can't believe
i'm so embarrassed but
all of that will be well will be
washed away by the onslaught of handheld
letters and so i don't know if you've
got a resource or a connection or
um what her situation is at school
whether teachers or students can write
letters or things like that but those
become worth their weight in gold
for somebody holding into their heart
um and then here's what i would do if
i'm you so i'm just thinking fast
forwarding i'm in your situation i got
two young kids i get the same call and i
race over the hospital and they tell me
that we've did they give her charcoal
and pump her stomach and all that
no they did not they just did blood work
and tested and waited till her tylenol
levels came down oh okay so they just
let that one ride huh
yeah yeah
and that
that's a scary one i had us my son ate a
handful of tylenol and they said we'll
know if his liver stops and that's a
scary scary moment right
yeah
that's one of the scariest moments of my
life i was waiting for that test um he
just they look like candy and my son
popped a bunch and they said we'll know
if his liver stops that's about the best
we can do
and
yeah i remember that
um
so i would get on the phone with the
school counselor
have you talked to her
or him i i have yeah okay
they should have a resource that they
trust
and that's that's where if you can get a
insurance referral and you can go
through there that's where i would go
because they will have looped with
untold numbers of students and their
parents in this very same situation that
nobody knows about
students disappear and they come back
two weeks later and they're integrated
back into school but that would be the
person i would go to in my local
community if i was in the same same
situation you're in
okay
and they should they'll probably give
you two or three and go in and visit
with them and go with your gut okay your
mom you know
and if you start feeling anxious
right yeah
do you struggle with anxiety
oh yeah yeah yeah the apple doesn't fall
far from the tree
so marie you're worth the work too
i'm serious
i know but i'm
i'm i'm not currently in trouble i'm
okay you're not
you're not
my baby is i know but so is marie
so is marie
hey
am i right
yes yeah i've done this too long marie i
promise you
you're worth the work too
and
when you can
then everybody can breathe
okay
will you call somebody today
absolutely yes
yeah
i did yesterday i i did i did yesterday
i i made a phone call yesterday and yeah
i'm you promise
i guess absolutely i did yeah i promise
will you actually go through with it
because you're gonna get really anxious
or you're gonna go once you're gonna be
done
will you please go i will yes sir i will
okay
my heart's with you marie
i appreciate it thank you do you have
people you can sit with
and now i made it weird and you're
trying to get off the phone i'm telling
you right now
i have no idea
okay
yeah
breathe it's it's it sucks it's un
unimaginable if you haven't been sitting
in this situation
how do we get here right
the emotions are really weird
you get really angry
and then you get really sad yeah
and i love her so much but i'm so mad at
her and i'm
it's hard and then you feel guilty and
you're a crappy mom because you're mad
at your daughter and you're not
it's okay to be mad it's okay to be
raged out it's okay to be pissed off
it's okay to regret the last all those
feelings and things are real they're not
truthful but they're real and do you can
you tell the difference there
yes yes
so feel them and have somebody you can
say i'm out loud to
write them down hey i'm so pissed off at
you how dare you try to take the most
precious thing in the world from me how
dare you do that
how dare you ex-husband fill in the
blank of all that fun stuff you could
just pile on that you know you could
dump in that yeah right all of it
yeah
it's real it's not all true but it's
real
yeah
and you well i can tell you right now
marie you don't believe you're worth
fixing right now and fixing's a bad
thing you don't feel like you're worth
healing right now because your baby's in
the hospital
and what i'm telling you is you got to
eat and you got to sleep and you got to
have oxygen too
and you've heard that being said over
and over and over again that you got to
put your oxygen mask on first and it is
never more true than right now
okay
i hear you
you promise i'm only telling this guy i
love you i i'm telling you right now
i'm trying i know you are this isn't it
it's not a try it's not like work hard
or do harder i'm not trying to be jocko
here right i'm i'm trying to tell you
i came home last night and ate a bag of
beef jerky and drank a bottle of wine in
the bubble
bath was good for me
hey you get one of those and you already
burned it but you get one right
yeah and you probably woke up this
morning
with the greatest guess of all time is
that fair
it was fun
i've got still got um i still don't
smell well after covet and
i'm even i'm glad i'm not in the
pennsylvania area but listen you got you
get you get one or two of those but i
wanna make sure you got someone you can
call and say i'm really pissed off right
now and they're not gonna say well you
shouldn't be they're gonna say i know i
hate that for you it sucks come over i
do i i i do i have some i have some good
friends and i've been in contact with
them and yes
yes
if the school counselor gives you
nothing go with the resources that the
hospital is going to get you those are
your only choices okay okay follow your
gut it's going to be uncomfortable it's
going to be hard your daughter's going
to text you and say i wish i wasn't here
that some of that stuff is part of the
entry of this deal
right healing from this is gonna be hard
lots of shame lots of embarrassment lots
of people that have some major
psychiatric disorders in
patient care with her going
whoa i'm not here right and i've had
some experiences where that was the
greatest thing ever for a young person
like whoa i've got a lot
different situation than some of these
folks here
okay okay um and it will be hard trust
the doctors here and i know that's gonna
be the hardest thing in the world
got it yeah got it marie we are all 100
behind you
let us know how the next few days go
let us know if she gets into a hospital
and we will be rooting for you rooting
for you rooting for you thank you so so
much for that call
every parent out there when your kid
gets sick and something's going
wrong with your kids in the hospital
everything in our body says let's dump
125 of who we are into that situation
and what i want to tell you is you got
to stop and back out because you got to
be okay
ask my baby forget all that i'm telling
you right now i've been to too many
hospitals with too many parents and sat
for too long in these situations
you got to eat you got to breathe you
got to check in with people that you
love you gotta sleep
you gotta be clear-headed and listen to
doctors you gotta write things down you
gotta have friends that you can call and
weep bitterly with and say i hate
everything and i'm pissed off about
everything and i'm angry about
everything
and i miss my baby and i love her all in
the same sentence and they're not gonna
think you're crazy
you gotta have all of that stuff
and you gotta do the hardest thing in
the world which is trust right now
experts you gotta trust the doctors you
gotta trust the people that
it's hard hard hard marie hard marie
but your daughter's gonna be okay
she's gonna come out and go i'm gonna
heal i'm gonna be better and you're
gonna have a group of people rally
around you
thank you so so much for being honest
and vulnerable marie thank you so much
for this call